- What's been your best costume?
- [Group] Um ...
- Do you want me to start, okay?
- You go.
- Yeah.
- I was a cocktail
waitress at a comedy club
and I knew that there was,
I think it was like
500 bucks you could win
and I was poor.
So I was like, I went to Walmart
'cause it was late in the game.
I had like three jobs and I was like,
"Dang, I don't have a costume
and I need this money."
So I got an extra, extra,
extra large cow costume
before I needed any kind of XL (chuckles)
I was really small and
literally the udders were
dragging on the ground
and I cut the nipples
(laughing) like the udders
and I'm squirting alcohol
through them.
- Oh!
Won the money!
(crowd clapping and laughing)
- That is amazing.
- Yes!
- I won the money.
- Of course you did.
- What's some of your
favorites or with your kids?
- That's genius.
- Our kid make us dress up now,
which...
- Yeah!
- Oh my, yeah so do mine.
- We don't like it.
- I like it.
Our families ...
- It's a lot of pressure.
- I love it.
- No, we do themed,
- They do themes.
- Yep.
- What did y'all do last year?
- Y'all do family themes?
- We were, we were,
- Star Wars.
- [Group] Star Wars.
- Right?
- Star Wars, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, these are not
the droids you're looking for.
(laughter)